hello everyone happy to see you again um
i haven't been in front of the camera
like this for quite a long time
uh and i thought that'd give you a bit
of a an update for the channel
especially since very recently we've hit
the 100 000 subscriber which i had no
idea would have happened
so first i'd like to apologize for the
slight uh slowdown in the pace of videos
uh in the past few months
as probably can relate it's been way
more difficult than usual to shoot
videos to travel
lots of events have been cancelled
therefore
not so much material to to take
for interviews likewise it's been more
difficult to go and see people to talk
to people
and uh given that i much prefer the
face-to-face
sort of interactions rather than the you
know zoom meetings and stuff like that
of course i've been doing less of it
however i'm hoping to resume that
i didn't completely stop though you know
one of the things that i've been doing
i've been putting my energy and gear to
the service of the ikikai and um i've
had them set up the stream for the
kagamibiraki
two years in a row now
and i went last year at in iwama to film
the aikitai so all that material was
shot
and i put it to the disposal of the
aikikai who's published it on their
channel so some of it is there some of
it was taken down because they don't
plan to have a long-term diffusion
but
it's it's viewable it's there and i was
very happy to help them out with that
technical side but that explains
that that's the reason why you haven't
seen that content on my channel that
being said um
there's more stuff that's uh coming on
the way but one thing that i want to
show you that came by the post uh
recently
is that uh that bad boy here
uh
that came from youtube
to celebrate the 100 000 subscriber on
the channel and you know what
it's probably the first time and the
last time we're going to do an unboxing
on this uh channel so i'm going to show
you what's inside i mean
i'm seeing here that is a bit of a dance
in the in the box uh but we'll see what
what happens um so
there you go
so let's crack this one open uh as you
can see i've already cut the tape on the
side because i was a bit concerned with
the
dance here in the box that it might be
damaged but luckily it's not so i'll
show you what's inside uh so
connect it like this
and
nice protection you can see the didn't
make it through so that was what
reassured me
so we have a little bit of a
quality control card here
and a letter by uh the ceo of youtube so
congratulating us for 100 000
subscribers
silver award and so on
okay
so that's a nice letter i'll probably
keep it somewhere
and
of course
the
piece itself
so there you go
okay
nice
silver plate here
here in japan 100 000 subscribers
youtube
nice and shiny uh
very shiny actually
and quite heavy too
quite heavy too so that's that's really
nice so there you go
that's the plate
and uh it's 100 000 subscribers i hope
you can see it i hope it's in focus it's
probably reflecting a lot so you're
seeing all my setup
the camera and the lights and so on
uh but of course i'd like to thank you
for uh making that happen uh thanks to
your viewership
thanks to your comments your likes your
dislikes as well and they also count in
the ranking
and that's you know uh made the channel
that's pushed the channel uh and made it
somewhat popular which
i guess for
an aikido specific channel uh you know
hundred thousand is a good number i
doubt that they'll ever get the golden
um
equivalent of this one which i think is
a million subscribers so that is not
going to happen but really hundred
thousand subscribers that's that's a big
milestone uh i didn't think we could
make it to be honest uh but i'm quite
happy to that that to see that yeah the
aikido community can actually
uh gather around around media like that
and and i hope
that same success to uh you know to
friends of mine like you know aikido
journal saido all those people that
deserve just as much if not more
subscribers and you know go and support
them and hopefully we can
you know have some good
media video providers for the aikido
community and again thank you very much
everyone for making that happen i'm very
much appreciated and that's what that's
what this reminds me uh reminds me of
um
so i thought uh i would give you a bit
of an update of what's going to come
soon
as i said i'm going to resume
some of the interviews
hopefully the events will start again i
will be able to report that
excuse me
and
you're gonna see the
an increase in the rate of videos
happening
one thing though that i've decided as
well uh i decided i would
make a bit of an effort to be
a bit more interactive uh in front of
the camera like this
with you guys to get your feedback and
to establish some sort of of discussion
between us because from my side uh i've
been a bit reluctant of putting myself
like this in the open
but i feel that at this stage
well i mean with the channel like this
there is a bit of responsibility
and
you have to take feedback and the best
way to take feedback is to take directly
with you guys and interact so one of the
ways this is going to happen
is
i'm going to organize some live streams
uh
and don't worry just just not only me
with the camera but uh with guests with
good friends of mine uh rather prominent
people in the martial arts aikido
community and engage in discussions with
those people
live and wildlife
so that you guys can interact with us as
we go through questions comments and so
on now frankly i've never done it before
so don't hold your breath in time to the
quality but
you know this is very much something
that i would like to try and to see how
we can get that conversation going
uh to get your feedback so the first
person that i'm going to have on one of
those streams will be aikido journals
josh gold
who took over as you know probably from
the late stanley pranin so
josh is a very interesting guy
very forward thinking doing a lot of
good for aikido so we'll be him and i
talking about this
uh and you'll get the chance to ask us
questions um
as we go and we'll be able to interact
with you in that sense so i'll announce
the date
when we've worked out the details josh
is just as excited about it as i am
and
hopefully i'll have a few more down the
line
through the next few weeks or months
so i guess that wraps it up
thank you again very much for your
support and i will see you on the next
video thank you
bye
you